ashley herrmann first noticed he had
trouble walking in 2013.
a year later he was diagnosed with
progressive multiple sclerosis
and doctors warned him it will be a
matter of time before he needed a
wheelchair
it's got progressively worse over the
last five
six years in that i now have
trouble with my right hand side of my
body
moving my arm and moving my leg
to the point where i can't really go for
long walks i can walk with a stick
but i do have a distinctive
limp as i walk there is currently
nothing that can slow down progressive
ms
but a brand new clinical trial is
promising to change that
called octopus scientists say it could
develop new options for treatment up to
three times faster
octopus is revolutionary it's going to
speed up the development of those much
needed
life life-changing new treatments for
people with progressive forms of ms
that currently have no treatments that
can stop their ms getting worse
so we'll be able to test new treatments
more quickly by testing them together
but also by combining trial phases it
will be much quicker much more efficient
for the scientists but also for people
involved in the trial
and we do believe it will stop ms don't
stop thinking about tomorrow
don't stop the illness attacks the
nerves in the body
it's painful and disabling but this
trial which hopes to recruit volunteers
later this year
has given hope to some who suffer from
it
i've got young children i want to still
be as active
as i can for them so that i'm not
confined to a wheelchair
i'm not stuck in doors all day every day
i can still have
as reason as reasonably an active life
as possible and for many like ashley
it's that hope
that keeps them going milena
vaselinovich
sky news